PROFESSOR: OK.
We are about to start
week two of our course.
Week two is very
rich in content.
Quite a lot of material for
you to see in your videos.
Take your time.
That's the beauty
of these courses.
You do it according to your
own drummer, so to speak.
But we think we've got some
very exciting and important work
for you ahead.
What you're going
to do is going to be
using interactive tools online.
You're going to
look at aperture,
you're going to look
at point of view,
you're going to
look at exposure,
you're going to look at ISO,
all those highly technical
issues that you have to know.
I'm going to continue to say
to you, read your manual.
There's no way I could teach you
every camera there is around.
But now we get to the
nitty-gritty of the course
and you're going to
have a blast, I promise.
Have fun.